bonjour thierry amouroux bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct matin avec
nous sur rt france il manquerait encore
500 millions d'euros au moins pour le
secteur de la santé ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ce constat
il faut mettre davantage de moyens pour
inverser la vapeur par là actuellement
nous sommes dans un cercle infernal
où depuis des années on avait coupé les
moyens aux hôpitaux en supprimant des
lions supprimant des postes y compris
pendant l'épidémie koji parce que il ya
selon les propres chiffres du ministère
sera 1700 lui qui ont été fermées en
2020 en pleine épidémie qu'ovide et en
2021 nous avons dû faire face à 1,4
milliard d'économies sur sur les
hôpitaux et donc va en fait la charge de
travail de ces coques menthe et les
conditions de travail ne sont que se
dégrader ce qui entraîne le départ de
soignants infirmiers étreignant et plus
vous en haïti pas plus à charge de
travail augmente ce qui reste et ce qui
entraîne de nouveau départ dont il faut
vraiment inverser le cirque hulene
sortir de ce cercle infernal et pour ça
il faut mettre les moyens c'est à dire
qu'il faut leur ouvrir des lits pour
répondre aux besoins de santé de la
population parce que nous sommes
vraiment en dessous les milieux
européens les moyens de l'état est en
train dé mettre les moyens pour les
hôpitaux on l'a vu encore hier olivier
ferrand qui étaient en normandie pour
promettre encore une enveloppe
supplémentaire
ouimette des enveloppes mais ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas suffisant il ya du
milliard d'économies qui ont été faits
sur sur les hôpitaux ces dernières
années dont 1,4 milliard le mois dernier
et
l'année dernière et là il donne
et quelques millions part ci quelques
millions par là ça ne compense pas les
choses sont vraiment inverser les choses
rouvrir donc délit créé des postes mais
compatible avec la qualité des soins par
aujourd'hui si vous proposer un poste
d'infirmière pour 15 patients de
médecine ou de chirurgie ou un poste
d'infirmière pour 80 à 120 résidents en
ehpad est bien bien sûr ces postes
restent vacants parce que derrière il ya
un problème de qualité des soins voire
de maltraitance institutionnelle
donc il faut vraiment être ré enchanter
l'hôpital et est en sorte que les gens
aient envie de rester et ensuite que les
soignants qui sont parties aient envie
de revenir parce que là nous sommes sur
une vague de départs depuis le mois de
juin qui a entraîné des fermetures de
lits sur l'ensemble du territoire dans
les chu dont les hôpitaux dans les ehpad
oui on l'a vu les les petits hôpitaux de
campagne sont particulièrement touchés
par par ces départs on a vu par exemple
que certains urgentistes sont seuls là
où ils étaient 7 auparavant
oui bien sûr parce qu il cumule à la
fois les problèmes de l'hôpital et le
problème de la désertification
des
des campagnes des petites villes et
cetera donc c'est en plus haut encore
plus dur en zone rurale ou suburbaines
parce que vous avez à la fois la vie
privée et la vie professionnelle qui
sont compliquées on a vu aussi un
notamment à marseille ces infirmiers
anesthésistes entamé ce qu'on appelle
une semaine deux blocs mort c'est aussi
un statut à revoir pour ses personnels
une reconnaissance oui oui il ya un vrai
problème de reconnaissance
professionnelle des compétences autonome
à la fois des infirmières qui sont bac
+3 et puis de fées d'infirmières
spécialisées que sont les iad qui après
quelques années d'expérience
professionnelle comme infirmière on fait
un master
pour cette nouvelle fonction et donc
sont sous payés et je ne sont pas
reconnus à la hauteur de leurs
compétences
il faut bien comprendre qu'avec cinq
années d'études ils ont le même niveau
d'études qui ne veut qu'une sage-femme
or on le reconnaît que l'institut
d'autres filières médicales et pas de
professionnels de santé à part entière
et ses personnels est-ce que ça
participe justement cette non
reconnaissance mais saches pas main
demande une meilleure reconnaissance de
leur profession est-ce que ça participe
au départ de ces personnels vers
peut-être d'autres pays voisins oui bien
sûr pour pour une à une infirmière le
chalet est doublée en amphi fait et au
luxembourg et puis au delà du salaire
bas vous avez
reconnaissance sur le lieu de travail
qui n'est pas du tout au rendez vous par
rapport justement
à toute l'autonomie de la profession et
puis vous avez le fait que la
réglementation est largement régressive
par rapport à nos compétences prendre
donc
safa nous freine dans notre activité et
puis les conditions de travail sont
déplorables lorsque l'on oblige
régulièrement à à revenir sur vos jours
de repos à a enchaîné équipes du matin
qui d'après midi ben ça use pourquoi ça
n'avance pas c'est tout le temps thierry
amouroux pourquoi ça n'avance pas cette
question sur les salaires
et bien parce que le gouvernement estime
qu'il a fait déjà un effort mais nous ce
que l'on constate c'est que avant nous
les avants de ségur de la santé nous
étions moins 20% sous le salaire
infirmiers moyen européen là nous sommes
à moins 10% donc il ya encore beaucoup
de chemin à faire pour que la france
rejet wren la moyenne européenne pour ce
qui est des salaires infirmiers donc il
faut vraiment faire en sorte que les
gens arrêtent de partie et que ceux qui
sont déjà partis puissent puisse revenir
et pour ça améliorer les conditions de
travail la reconnaissance des
compétences et les revalorisations
salariales merci beaucoup lamoureux et
d'avoir répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur rt france